Shay and Irving back in the building and
I think he did pretty well with his pics
from last week I got him off cometh you
went four and two last week Bangor let's
see one out right army won outright Ole
Miss won outright with Wyoming mm-hmm so
now 27 24 and three but you did lose the
bet with the front row Paulie said that
they were gonna take Iowa and they were
gonna take the ten points first half you
lost that once he lost a Hyundai go
unfair but yeah now Iowa was leading 31
17 at halftime so what's where do we
stand there Paulie with Shannon or me
so we're up 200 bucks for the year on
him we have four bets to present him for
this week he could pick any two of the
four I'll go rapid fire okay
Iowa getting 12 versus Michigan are
versus um Wisconsin Iowa getting 12 will
take Iowa for the game
I will getting 12 you going Georgia
given two and a half this weekend we'll
take Georgia next one is TCU Oklahoma
the over-under is 61 we will take the
over in that and then uh parlez if you
want a piece of this we're talking now
we're talking army Duke we want army
getting three at Mikey Stadium and we
want the under of 49 points okay hold on
now here comes
so you're saying army - three yeah we
wind armageddon yeah and uh and we want
the under army Duke what's the number 49
Oh
so I gotta take Duke in the / yes or you
could take any two of the others so Duke
- three in the / yeah I'm taking Auburn
give me three instead of two and a half
deal all right
I don't give me a burn and I'm gonna
take the parlay yes but then on Monday
when I talk to you then you say paulie's
a pusher he is a blur that's true yeah
that lady oh I okay you're a man you'd
also take you know what's got say if I'm
a man I was born with the mustache I
didn't have to take a month to grow mine
Paulie okay how much to out if I'm a man
okay give me your picks for this weekend
and I do have something to unveil that
for Seaton's wheel of punishment first
going four and two last week Danny yeah
didn't hear a whole lot of chirping on
the internet just want to put that out
there when I do yes I am the worst son
of a gun that's ever been anywhere on
the planet so the rest of y'all can go
to hell
Virginia Tech minus three at Georgia
Tech TCU plus 7 at Sooners I got Auburn
plus three against ugga that's a home
game BC plus three wakes a pick'em and
I'm a Southern Miss minus ten I'm on the
fence Danny I'm on the fence for the
Catholics and okie light I'm scared I'm
confused that number scares you from a
Notre Dame force powdered a minus three
at Miami and Miami's been fraudulent all
year barely been winning I know Notre
Dame has been rolling I know a number
should be bigger and it's smaller
they're trying to trap me they're trying
to push me into bettin them I'm scared
and then Oh key light minus six and a
half at Ames
that'll make no damn sense that does not
make sense either I'm scared but
depending on how many of these I have it
might just happen well you got okay
that's a survey sir Danny I had to bring
my own because I didn't want to Baptist
in here didn't have me alcohol the whole
day we we don't encourage that during
the show Seton lost a wheel of
punishment
and he had to come up with a t-shirt
here so I want to show you this is the
t-shirt that we came up with Holy Mother
of God so that's the Seton hey girl
he's naked with a champagne bottle
strategically placed in front of the
fireplace that shirts awesome he
shouldn't have to wear that oh wait you
don't think this is punishment to wear
it during entire show it's Kurt's rad
hilarious well I was going to making
where Donald Trump shirt oh wow look at
that that is uh that's a fireside chat
if that's a poster right there that's
that's a tinder profile you swipe left
here
I like that all right so see on Monday
you're gonna have one of them where
there has been the worst day of
punishments ever for Paul yes - look at
that shirt he's got Andrew walking
around in yoga pants and he can't help
that was the best piece of pork I che
have a great weekend as always good luck
to your Cowboys without I don't even
want Danny it's over it's a wrap
now stop he should have took the
punishment in the beginning like you
said like everybody said no so we got to
play the Eagles twice we got to play the
skins again it's over Danny you know how
many times EQ Elliot was in there
blocking on a pass play and how many
times he took something on 33% of pass
plays he's in there blocking on pass
protection Alfred Morris is gonna do
that now okay have fun
so gingers gonna air it out 62 times a
game here comes do the Cowboys make the
playoffs nope okay nope not no more well
it could be what but we only punish if
it means that the Commissioner doesn't
get another contract you're fine with
that Danny there's a trade off that's a
pretty damn good one you would take the
Cowboys not making the playoffs if it
meant Roger Goodell wasn't back not just
wooden back but was unemployed and
bankrupt in 60 days he's not gonna be
bankrupt son of a politician for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]